bonsoir raphaël est ce que vous en savez
plus sur le bilan humain de ces
intempéries en belgique
un bilan qui est difficile à chiffrer un
pour l'instant mes os qu'on est sûr
c'est qu'il ya au moins une vingtaine de
personnes décédées est encore au moins
une vingtaine d'autres personnes portées
disparues dont on est sans nouvelles
donc le bilan pourrait malheureusement
s'alourdir
et ce malgré le travail des 500
secouristes qui ont été mobilisés sur
tout le pays et notamment des militaires
qui ont été réquisitionnés tu es le
début dès les premières heures de la
catastrophe
et puis il ya eu aussi cette dizaine de
secours qui secouriste pardon venus
d'italie d'allemagne
et puis de france va prêter main forte
est ce que l'on en sait plus sur les
dégâts matériels alors là aussi un c'est
incalculable
il y a littéralement des maisons qui se
sont effondrées effondré perdant à
certains endroits pour l'instant il ya
des communes qui n'ont toujours pas
d'eau potable
et puis il y à ces centaines ces
milliers de personnes qui n'ont toujours
pas d'électricité dans la province de
liège ont été nombreux à près de 17
mille foyers qui n'ont toujours pas
d'électricité
et puis il ya les infrastructures
ferroviaires qui ont été durement
touchées notamment sur des axes qui
reliait les principales wallonie où les
intempéries ou ont frappé très durement
et puis aussi sur des axes reliant vers
la capitale vers bruxelles alors tous
ces dégâts matériels il faudra des
semaines pour voir des mois peut-être
pour pouvoir les réparer totalement la
catastrophe et est important merci
beaucoup raphaël blanc d'amour pour
toutes ces précisions en direct de
bruxelles